et
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les républicains sont
rassemblés pour bâtir l'avenir de la
france une france qui s'engage pour son
école sans une école qui puisse remplir
correctement ses missions
notre pays et son avenir sont affaiblis
l'école c'est d'abord la transmission de
savoirs et de connaissances qui prépare
les élèves à la vie professionnelle et à
la liberté c'est aussi l'apprentissage
du respect et des valeurs de la france
par le futur citoyen mais l'école s'est
elle assume promesse oubliée celle de la
réduction des inégalités
les républicains aux côtés des
enseignants veulent rétablir la
confiance entre les français et leur
école
[Musique]